que deviennent vos vieux téléphone là on
est dans un espèce de cimetière des
vieux téléphone avec un ola ola Siemens
ça doit être
1995 999 j'en sais rien on a un vieux
BlackBerry on a des téléphones à clapet
ça c'est un téléphone avec clapet de
BenQ je sais même pas que BenQ au
téléphone avec clapet on a un vieux
Motorola à clapet il y en a pour 400 kg
de vieux téléphone on est chez Smart
dans le sud de la France et ils vont les
faire recycler c'est-à-dire que vous
avez toutes les batteries qui sont
enlevées et ils sont recyclés en France
comme quoi rien ne se perd tout se
transforme c'est du Lavoisier mais au
niveau des téléphones je trouve ça
marrant de venir recycler ces trucs là
c'est important c'est bien pour la
planète est-ce que vous vous allez faire
ces clés vos vieux téléphone ou pas
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires